like many of you I'm often frustrated by
the democratic process it's messy it's
complicated it's often inefficient our
political leaders feel disconnected from
the concerns of ordinary people many
feel that voting every few years for the
leaders disconnected from their daily
challenges is pointless but before we
reject democracy let's imagine what it
could be and I believe that African
activists are redefining democracy by
putting protests at its centre what I
referred to as protest democracy
international organizations and academic
experts define democracy as regular
multi-party electoral competition but
democracy should not only be about
elites competing at the ballot box for
it to have meaning it's something we
must engage in every day when I say
protest democracy I'm challenging how we
think about democratic action during
democracy has only elections is no
longer adequate and threatens democracy
itself so we must protest democracy to
give it a renewed meaning what would
this look like and we need to turn to
African societies where ordinary people
are increasingly taking to the streets
to transform their lives African social
movements have often been at the
forefront of conceptualizing democracy
in this way this may come as a surprise
to those of us who think that the only
way Africans engage in politics is to
the barrel of the gun but increasingly
young people are taking to the streets
and abandoning organized violence in
favor are more effective nonviolent
action
much of the past two decades talking to
African activists both violent and
nonviolent across Africa young people
are rising up to challenge almost every
type of regime known to humanity this is
my friend Fiat he's a rapper from
Senegal
he led a large movement in Senegal that
was successful and preventing the
president from stealing a third term
from Morocco to the Soto young people
are rising up against entrenched
monarchies in Egypt and Sudan against
brutal dictatorships in Uganda and
Ethiopia against powerful militarized
state with quasi democratic veneers in
South Africa for this image is taken and
Burundi against democratically elected
leaders who have done little to improve
the conditions for ordinary people
across the continent protest is not
exceptional but a normal part of life
Africans use protests to challenge both
dictators as well as power cuts in a way
Africans are protesting democracy itself
and reaching its possibilities for us
all there have been two major waves of
African protest and we are currently
living through the third which began
around 2005 it includes the so-called
Arab Spring which took place mostly on
the continent the first wave took place
in the 1940s and 1950s and led to
Africa's decolonization Kwame Nkrumah
that a broad coalition in Ghana that
overthrew British rule providing a
template for nonviolent movements
globally the second wave took place in
the 1980s and 1990s against austerity
measures that imposed harsh conditions
on African economies these protests led
to the overthrow of autocratic regimes
and led to the introduction of
multi-party elections across the
continent be ongoing third-wave is
correcting the shortcomings of the
earlier two if the first wave brought
liberation were not democracy and the
second elections
but only for the elites then it is the
third wave that is most concerned with
transforming democracy into the rule of
the people it includes movements like
yin amar in Senegal below a Centurion in
Burkina Faso tamuka in Zimbabwe lucha
and fill in be in the Democratic
Republic of Congo movements that work
outside abort more conventional
nongovernmental organizations and
political parties to challenge the
economic and political system itself
often a great risk brilliant young
activists like Lucas Fred Booma have
been detained and tortured often with
little to no outcry from the
international community the list goes on
as you can see from some of the data we
collected there have been large popular
protests in over 40 African countries
since 2005 and if you look you recognize
it in 2011 the year of the so-called
Arab Spring was actually the spike of
this broader wave contrary to popular
belief many of these protests have been
successful we know of the dictators
falling in Tunisia and in Egypt our
popular movements have prevented
presidents from stealing third terms in
Senegal and Malawi and Burkina Faso as
well what's driving the sub surge of
protests demographically Africa is both
the youngest and the fastest-growing
continent with the largest age gap
between the people and their rulers
it is urbanizing at a tremendous pace
economically African countries have been
growing for over a decade now largely
driven by investments from Asia but
little of this wealth is trickling down
formal jobs in the industrial sector are
actually decreasing with informal labour
the only option left for people to eke
out a living as a result inequality is
skyrocketing and political leaders are
increasingly disconnected from their
much younger populations for those of us
from outside of Africa we're familiar
with parts of this story a massive spike
in inequality the product of the decline
in good jobs for good wages that were
once considered the hallmark of an
advanced society
capture of our political parties by
elites accompanied by the hollowing out
of civil society the ones provided a
voice to ordinary people that's sinking
feeling no matter what you do
external factors related to the global
economy can disrupt our lives for the
worse our political leaders seem
helpless insisting on austerity even as
public goods diminish to levels unseen
in decades and this is not misses when
they're not succumbing to exclusionary
nationalism blaming our woes on the weak
rather than the powerful but those of us
from North America and Western Europe
considered to be new has been the normal
condition of African life since the
1970s so who better to learn from and
those who've been engaged in resistance
to these conditions for the longest
period of time what can we learn from
African protest democracy first
democracy must begin with ordinary
people doing democracy is only elections
has led to widespread disillusionment
who must instead work to Center ordinary
people in democratic life protest
provides us one way to do that
regardless of your age sexuality your
gender whether you're a citizen or non
citizen able-bodied are disabled
anyone can participate in contrast to
elections protests are not confined by
rigid electoral cycles they offer a much
more immediate form of action in our era
of instant feedback second my protests
may be messy this is what makes them
powerful protests are contentious and
contested processes defined by
contingent actions often devoid of clear
messaging characterized by incomplete
organization these dynamics are what
makes it easy to dismiss protests as
riots are to assume their limited
political utility it also makes them
easier to suppress - too often
governments do not view protests as
elementary - democracy instead they
violently crush social movements or work
to discredit their message
third as I've already hinted protest is
the space from which new political
imaginations may emerge protests are
about coloring outside the lines a way
for ordinary people
to rewrite the rules of the game the too
many field are stacked against them many
young people in Africa have grown up in
societies where a single ruler has led
has ruled their entire lives protest is
the space for new possibilities to
emerge as young people begin to discover
their own power consider the situation
of my friend lindomar sarira
a single mother of five who is leading
protests against Mugabe regime in
Zimbabwe she has been beaten arrested
harassed but Linda persevered because
she told me a few months ago protest has
given her a sense of meaning and
direction and though she knows the odds
against her in the purse of years like
Linda and other young African activists
we all must work to redefine democracy
as something more than just elections
and political parties democracy is a
creative process and protest has always
been the vehicle for expanding our
political imaginations beyond what we
are told is possible a scientist
[Applause]
[Music]